[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace con méxico hoy
desde cuentepec en morelos dedicamos el
programa a los 500 años de la caída de
tenochtitlan que marcó el inicio de la
dominación española una conmemoración
que ha generado debates con españa' y
grandes discusiones sobre la identidad
mexicana y la revisión del pasado desde
la óptica oficial aquí encontramos a
karina una artesana alfarera que
conserva la técnica prehispánica y a
victorino un maestro de la uac y que
asegura que 500 años después continúa la
represión contra los pueblos originarios
entrevistamos a la historiadora úrsula
camba sobre estas controversias que
rodean al aniversario en el que el
presidente lópez obrador impulsa la
narrativa de pedir perdón a los pueblos
indígenas en el zócalo de la ciudad de
mexico algunos asistentes nos dicen lo
que significa para ellos este
aniversario
karina es una artesana de cuentepec
morelos aquí las mujeres se han
transmitido de generación en generación
la tradición de la alfarería con una
técnica prehispánica
pues me siento orgullosa de conservar y
de poder practicar esta
esta actividad ya que mi abuelita
también le he dicho que está muy bien
que ella siguió y que no perdieran la
tradición y también ella me dice que yo
siga conservando la y que no deje de
hacer las piezas de barro
con el apoyo de expertas como bobby
stromberg especialista en antropología
del arte y cristina faesler promotora de
la cultura las artesanas de contepec
participan en un proyecto para exponer
su trabajo artesanal en el museo de
culturas populares
quiero decir que el contexto del museo
nacional de culturas populares es un
lugar ideal para hablar y explorar y
investigar esta cuestión de la
producción artística y la identidad
indígena
esta identidad no sólo se conserva con
la artesanía sino sobre todo mediante el
habla de su lengua materna
victorino es hijo de una ardilla y se
dedica a enseñar el nativo el concepto
de respuesta y hay una resistencia pero
más bien hay represión o entonces más
bien serían como 500 años de represión
hacia los pueblos originarios nativos o
indígenas en el peor de los casos como
pues regularmente no se etiquetan o
asegura que el estado lleva a cabo un
lingüista vio y ve simulación en la
narrativa de pedir perdón no puedes
pedir perdón
por un lado y por el otro lado seguir
como
matando a las lenguas matando a los
hablantes matando pues a la gente que
lucha por defender sus tierras su agua
victorino karina más de 90% de los casi
3000 habitantes de cuentepec son
hablantes de náhuatl y una lengua que
han rescatado durante 500 años y que
están decididos a preservar en un país
en el que hay más de 60 lenguas
originarias en peligro de extinción
y para detenernos en la importancia de
la memoria y la identidad a cinco siglos
de la conquista un episodio hoy sujeto a
debate acompáñenos a ver la entrevista
que previamente hicimos con la
historiadora úrsula camba
creo que uno de los mitos de las
inexactitudes más grandes y que da pie a
que la gente no comprende el pasado es
creer que los españoles conquistaron
méxico como si en mexico y existiera
como un país entonces el discurso es que
nos atacaron nos derrotaron nos
invadieron como si el país existiera y
sabemos que las naciones los estados
sólo una creación del siglo 19 que se
adjunta digamos el himno la bandera este
discurso de patria frente al extraño al
que desde fuera que antes no existe esta
nación mexicana pues no existe como tal
no es una cosa que se va en la identidad
cocinando y que después del siglo 19
impone ciertos valores patrios digamos
con los conoce tiene que identificar
pero es una es una creación es una cosa
artificial digamos
el presidente lópez obrador asegura que
la conquista fue un rotundo fracaso que
se cometieron atrocidades en aras de una
supuesta civilización y llama a
reconocer la grandeza de los pueblos
indígenas en este sentido ha habido una
serie de actividades desde el cambio de
nombre algunas calles hasta la
instalación de una maqueta monumental
del templo mayor en el zócalo de la
ciudad de mexico ahi recogimos el sentir
de la población a este respecto no se me
hace justo celebrar algo que para mí
significa muerte significa este una
cultura que desapareció este sabemos que
nosotros estamos
con la cultura arriesgada pero solamente
de lo que quedó de lo que era
anteriormente no podemos lamentar una
conquista debemos de decir bueno tengo
raíces tenemos estamos hechos de mil
cosas y de todas esas mil cosas tus
echarlas adelante y vip progresar es
sumamente importante es recordar esta
fecha
porque es la fundación de méxico
prácticamente a partir de estos hechos
se deriva el méxico actual entonces es
sumamente importante que todos los
mexicanos tengamos presente esos
acontecimientos fue la conquista
sinónimo de avasallamiento y saqueo debe
reconocerse la aportación derivada de
ese choque de culturas la polémica por
lo ocurrido hace 500 años da pie hoy a
reflexionar sobre los orígenes y el
presente de los mexicanos gracias por
acompañarnos en este programa y los
esperamos la próxima semana en enlace
con por france24
hasta pronto